und darüber als Gesamtsituation
und Pandemien machen zehn Rootkit-Spione
eine virusschleck ballerina mit
schwarzy außer ich predige scheint mir
eine Ewigkeit, um dort Piloten auszubilden
verbindung zu familien es ist in caen dies
Wochenende bei 36 Fällen danke für die Einladung
das ist ein Thema, das mich sehr interessiert
fast einen Zoll markierte er Salah Hamza nicht
ali mohmed schädel und stumm
es ist wahr, dass ich es früher tat
Gefangenschaft, also waren es mehrere
Tage und mehrere Nächte ganz allein in
Solar-Impuls
Es waren 20 Tage, aber mit einem Teamkollegen
in orbital breaking 3 ist was
Mir ist aufgefallen, dass es zwei sind
Möglichkeiten, eine Haft wie zu leben
dieses oder wir freuen uns, dass dies
fertig sein und wir zählen die Stunden die wir haben
Zähle die Tage, die wir uns sagen, aber die Zukunft
wird besser und es wird zur Tortur
Chinesisch, weil die Zeit vergeht
viel langsamer
oder wir konzentrieren uns auf
der gegenwärtige Moment darüber, drin zu sein
Wir leben in seinem Körper und hören zu
was wir denken
wir sind uns dessen bewusst und dabei
Moment dort im Voraus und die
Zeit zählt nicht mehr und wann wir ankommen
am Ende des Einschlussexperiments
ist nicht ganz verwundert, dass es dann schon geht
ob in einer Ballonkapsel
oder Solarflugzeug irgendwo in
seine Wohnung während der Haft
von den koranschiffen uns ich denke es ist
so ziemlich das gleiche, was Sie nicht müssen
Projekt in die Zukunft, weil es ist
viel schwerer als zu leben
der gegenwärtige moment und moma rationalisieren
innerhalb von vier bis fünf Tagen nach dem Zusammenstoß zwischen
wild gefahren, aber zu viele Drifts nicht
wissen, wer Ihre Familie ist
limousine nächsten 6. märz
weil in nancy 26 mt zion
wenn wir demonstrieren
Theater ist Manipulation, aber
es ist überhaupt keine echte Hypnose
Falls es nicht von dort ist, ist es nicht von dort
Therapie, die ich sehr finde
interessante und fallhypnotische Therapie
ist, dass wir es dem Patienten erlauben
Aufmerksamkeit von außen erwidern
nach innen sind wir normalerweise
wir schauen immer ausserhalb von uns
wir hören wir berühren wir fühlen mit
Hypnose erwidern wir diese Aufmerksamkeit
zu sich selbst hinein und dabei
Moment existiert dieser Sinn und wir spüren ihn
Atmung kann ihre Emotionen verwalten
mit Ängsten vorausschauend umgehen können bzw
Ängste usw.
und dann, wenn wir gut zurückkommen
können alles anwenden, was wir haben
erfahren in seiner Visualisierung und
Dafür gibt es wirklich eine Sache
wichtig ist, was die genannt wird
Sicher bitte die Montage ist es
Komfort und Sicherheit erleben
dass wir lernen können, uns zu entwickeln
in sich selbst und das ist sehr
wichtig, weil es im Leben gibt
Situationen, die uns alle betreffen können
entfernen können wir alles verlieren und das ist
dafür muss man lernen einzulegen
etwas sein, was niemand kann
uns mitzunehmen ist diese Beziehung mit
eine innere Stärke und das mit dem Auto
Hypnose wir entdecken es und wir verwenden
sehr sehr leicht Ziellinie kcn
Juden ist es Meditationspraxis
in diesem Main Event auf der Blind Side
beim Meditieren
Wir versuchen, den Geist zu beruhigen
Denken Sie so wenig wie möglich, wir versuchen es
habe keine Bilder, die drin bleiben
alle Sinne, in denen wir uns beruhigen wollen
Hypnose
Wir verwenden häufig Visualisierungen
miteinander reden therapeuten können mit uns reden
Wir können mit den Therapeuten sprechen
Also ich habe mit dem Verstand ist sehr sehr
aktiviere es
es stellt eine Welt her, in der wir
fühlt sich gut an
was ganz anders ist
Meditation
Ich hatte ein gut gebautes Zyxel-Gefühl
im Rektorat
Es ist wahr, als ich ein Kind war
wollte ein Entdecker werden wie ich
Großvater wie mein Vater wie der
Astronauten, die ich aber getroffen hatte
gleichzeitig war mir schwindelig u
Ich war in der Lage gewesen, mich in einen Baum zu erheben und
als ich einen Deltaflügel sah
Stehlen ist eine der ersten und die
delta dring flug, der in der schweiz flog
Ich sagte mir, das ist für mich, wenn ich
ich kann das machen
dann alles zu tun und ich wirklich
Verwendung von Alberta als Therapie
zu lernen, mich mit mir selbst zu verbinden
und in der Tat Vertrauen in meine zu haben
interne Ressourcen
weil sehr oft Leute, die haben
Angst vor etwas sind diejenigen, die
haben nicht gelernt, ihre zu benutzen
inneres Potenzial und wann wir uns setzen
in Situationen, in denen wir müssen
gut arbeiten
Nun, wir arbeiten gut, das war's
großes Paradoxon, wir haben Angst vor etwas
Sache, aber so wie wir sind, war ich 16
Jahren war ich auf 1000 2000 3000 Meter auf
oberirdisch mit Mutter kleiner Deltaflügel
und dann musste ich eben und machen
wenn wir nur wir tun müssen
stimuliert seine Leistung, wir stimulieren seine
Kreativität seine Aufmerksamkeit seine
Konzentration und Zusammenfassung
funktionierte viel besser und was
hat mich sehr amüsiert ist das dann
als ich mich auf die Prüfungen in der Schule vorbereitete
Ich war viel besser in der Schule, weil
dass ich gelernt hatte, mich zu konzentrieren und zu
Haben Sie keine Angst, dort Prüfungen zu sehen
löste sich von einem Clip ja nicht einfach
weil in der Tat, was Sie können
zu tun ist zu lernen, Ihre zu entwickeln
Sack voll und dann stell dir das vor
dieser Grat aus Felsen und Weg
absolut komfortabel und sicher
in der Visualisierung und wann dann
Sie machen
Aktion, um Ihre Sahne zu überqueren
Felsen und gut da ist es fps wird zurückkommen
diese Sicherheitserfahrung wird wiederkommen
und Sie werden sich viel wohler fühlen
um es dort vorzubereiten
Die Zukunft ist eng und es funktioniert gut für mich
Das habe ich meinen Kindern beigebracht
bereiten Prüfungen für Situationen vor
Schwierigkeiten in ihrem Leben usw.
und es ist lustig, weil das letzte
Zeit hatte ich eine meiner Töchter, die
waren in der Prüfung ich sag dir was
möchte eine kleine Hypnosesitzung
dich vorzubereiten
er sagte zu mir aber papa ich mache das alles
allein jetzt hast du mich genommen Ich habe mehr
brauchen Sie viel besucht von
ringo Ich gehe ruhig und es meine Kruste
Denken Sie daran, dass man in dieser Hinsicht nicht darf
Kommen Sie und sehen Sie sich unsere Dörfer Taffonneau an
der das Irdische ärgert, in dem er gründet a
17. September
nv, dass Tonia 6 und 10 zur Halbzeit
trotz allem wussten wir, dass es ein war
Ziel hinter Datum unter 6 Ohm rollt
jetzt 90 Jahre alt und ein Freund von dir
wird nach der Welt lieben
Teil der Tribünen und Luxor etc
solar impulse schauen sie sich ein datum an
Segler ein Mythos
André Borschberg Renzi von Cellectis und
Er gab die chinesische Krankheit in ja mir das zu
berührt mich sehr, weil du
Stellen Sie sich vor, dass Sie dieses Flugzeug haben
um die Welt fliegen
Es waren 15 Jahre Arbeit
Es waren 15 Jahre Forschung
Finance Team World-Technologie
gesponsert musste ich fliegen lernen a
Flugzeug, weil ich kein Pilot war
Flugzeug, als ich mein Projekt startete
Solar-Impuls
also alles viel aufwand
es ist eine Menge Schwierigkeiten und wann
Wir sehen das Flugzeug, das wir so wollen
aber es scheint so einfach
wenn sofiane erworben
slowakisch ficfa ja das ist ein gefühl
fantastisch in der Tat habe ich nicht
stolz darauf, um die Welt gereist zu sein
Solarflugzeug, aber ich bin stolz darauf
konnte dieses Projekt 15 Jahre lang mit aufbauen
all die Probleme, die alle hatten
Belastbarkeit, die es manchmal brauchte
Frustrationen Enttäuschungen, weil es
lief nicht so wie wir wollten und ich glaube
das muss man verstehen
großer Traum, der sich nicht von alleine erfüllt
ein großer Traum für alle von a
jeder, der etwas will
von ihrem Leben träumen sie davon, sie hoffen darauf
sie wollen es
aber es braucht viel Arbeit, um dorthin zu gelangen
ankommen und das können wir haben
ein wenig vergessen heute ist es notwendig
engagiere dich viel
Es ist eine Frage der Verantwortung
es ist eine Frage der Entscheidungsfindung
es ist auch eine Frage der Akzeptanz
Angst außen vor zu bleiben
so viele Menschen wagen es nicht zu versuchen
etwas, wovor sie Angst haben
zu verpassen, dann werden sie ausgelacht
Zum Glück habe ich es ziemlich schnell verpasst
in meinem Leben mehrere Dinge, also ich
bin es gewohnt, Leute zu sehen, die
lachte mich aus, aber jetzt bin ich es
berührt überhaupt nicht so, wenn es gibt
etwas, das ich versuchen möchte
Ich gehe dorthin, ich sage mir, das Schlimmste ist nicht
Verpassen Sie das Schlimmste, versuchen Sie es nicht ein wenig
Frédéric Loucrup Rose als
wir passieren dann entweder wir öffnen wir müssen
wirklich diese Gedränge mäht
Verstehe schon den Hinweis, aber mach dir keine Sorgen
aber es stimmt, mit 14 wollte ich meine
Motorrad für großartig sein
wie meine Freunde sein und dann müssen
Setzen Sie einen Helm auf, wenn niemand sonst
War kein Helm außer einem alten
Geselle
mir brach es meine Lust zu können
mach es wie die anderen und die anderen
lustig über mich und am Anfang war es sehr
schwer und dann sagte ich mir aber rein
gemacht
was ich tue ist richtig und es gibt keine
Anlass, Kritik zu berücksichtigen
oder Spott und es erlaubte mir a
gewisse Distanziertheit, die mich übrigens hat
erlaubte eine gewisse Unabhängigkeit
des Handelns und der Unabhängigkeit des Denkens
witzig war es damals aber nicht
es war mir später sehr nützlich, wenn überhaupt
wird noch a angeboten
Britische Markendiagnose
also habe ich es ihnen immer beigebracht
Frage, die ich ihnen beigebracht habe
dass alles, was sie lernte
die Schule könnte anders verstanden werden
von einem Kind aus einem anderen Kontinent von a
eine andere Religion aus einer anderen Kultur bzw
aus einer anderen Zeit
also ich habe vieles relativiert
die Gewissheiten, ihnen zu zeigen
klar gibt es das nicht
etwas wahr ist, was falsch ist
hängt davon ab, wie wir denken, also ich sie
viel mehr darüber gelernt, wie
offen sein, in allem zu denken
die Richtungen und das war sehr
nützlich, weil sie dann in der Lage waren
gelten, dass sie brillant haben
ihr Studium bestanden, aber ich nicht
verpflichtet gut zu machen hätte ich das gegeben
möchte eine sehr gute Rede halten
edel und verschwommen, die früh aufwachen, geschrieben
Kevin Bullock und sein Thema Mythos
biblisches tribal aber auch ramdam ist
eine Sprinter-Club-Sache
Es stimmt, dass zwischen dem 16. und
mit 30 lernte ich fliegen
Gegen den Wind war ich mit meinem Flügel
delta mit einem ultraleichten gleitschirm victoria des
Turbulenzen müssen wir bekämpfen und dann wir
entscheide, wo wir landen, dann kämpfen wir
um dorthin zu gelangen, auch wenn der Wind geht
in alle Richtungen
und dann sagte mir einer meiner Freunde, hör zu
Psychiater töten Ich möchte dich
nimm mit zum überqueren
der Atlantik in einem Ballon war ein
Rennen zwischen den USA und Europa
und ich war kein Ballonpilot
Also sagte ich ja, weil ich es bin
öffne immer einen Fremden und ich liebe es
entdecken Sie neue Dinge, aber
in mir sagte ich mir ich
Ich bin völlig verrückt, dass wir geschubst werden
Beim Wind können wir nichts tun, ich weiß
auch nicht, wenn wir ankommen
seck auf die andere Seite und dann war ich
nur einen Monat vor diesem Rennen in
China, um Medizin zu studieren
traditionelles Chinesisch als Teil von
meine Ausbildung als Psychiater und in a
Antiquitätengeschäft
Ich finde diese Medaille diese Medaille
Hier und da waren Hunderte
Hunderte, ich weiß nicht, warum ich habe
nahm dieses und ich komme zu dem
Verkäufer Ich sage ihm, ich will
Sag was
und sie erklären mir den satznamen weil
dass er nicht gut Englisch spreche, sagte er mir
wenn der Wind in die gleiche Richtung weht
dass deine Art es dir ein großes bringt
Glück und das war der Wendepunkt meiner
Leben, sagte ich mir, aber tatsächlich gibt es
eine andere Art zu fliegen und es gibt eine
eine andere Lebensweise
statt immer darum kämpfen zu müssen
was wir wollen, auch wenn es unmöglich ist
Vielleicht musst du das Leben benutzen
benutze sie yvan de la ville
also alles, was wir nicht kontrollieren
musste zustimmen, ins Unbekannte vorzudringen
aber es ist wahr, wie in einem Ballon
Du musst die Höhe ändern
wenn wir denn die Richtung ändern wollen
mit der die Atmosphäre gemacht wird
verschiedene Wetterschichten, die
alle haben Winde mit Richtungen
anders und im Leben ist es dasselbe
Sache im Leben, wenn wir an a denken
einziger Weg
gut wird in eine Richtung drängen, wenn wir
denke, es wird einen anderen Weg geben
andere mögliche Trajektorien und so weiter
das h der Ballast unserer Gewissheiten unserer
Überzeugungen unserer Gewohnheiten usw.
Sie können alle Ebenen in erkunden
die Stadt
alle Denkweisen dann wir
behält die Denkweise bei, die hineingeht
Richtung wollen wir auch wenn die
Wind ist nicht günstig, aber wir können
nichts ändert sich heute coronavirus
wir können nichts ändern
Es ist eine Pandemie, die wir haben
die Wirtschaft bricht zusammen usw.
etwas, was du nicht ändern kannst
Was benötigt wird, ist die Höhe zu ändern
Richtung ändern versuchen, was zu sehen
was können wir damit machen was sind die
Ereignisse, die in a verwendet werden können
Krise, um zu lernen, wie man es danach besser macht
die Krise als zuvor und in der Tat dies
Medaille ist da und es hat vollständig
hat meine Sicht auf das Leben im Schwimmbad verändert
Beton um 10 Uhr morgens tfe regiert ganz weiß noch
seine Anti-Unschärfe, die von Jahren bekannt ist
andré chick mouse oder göttliche des
Menschen und Konto zu dieser wilden Katze
für die Panzerabwehr Valérie und Griezmann
und wird den dazu nötigen Film machen
das ganze Jahr ist unzulässig
Er kämpfte Fuzzy, das ist riesig
Weg, um die Höhe zu ändern
moment da ist es sich zu sagen bis
heute
So habe ich früher mit dir gearbeitet
Nehmen Sie das Beispiel der Frau, die will
die ihren Mann verlassen will
der mann muss sich sagen ok was war unser
Art der Beziehung bisher
und was soll ich an meinem ändern
Verhalten meiner Art zu tun in
der relationale Modus, so dass die Beziehung
verbessert, das heißt, solange
Sie bleiben auf der gleichen Höhe
d.h. du machst es genauso
was es sinnlos ist, ändern zu wollen
irgendetwas wird es nichts geben
wird sich verändern
Sie haben die gleiche Art, wie Sie denken
gesperrt sind und wenn Sie damit einverstanden sind
denk anders und stell dich wieder rein
Frage und um Ihnen zu sagen, wie es ist
dass ich anders funktionieren könnte
An diesem Punkt haben Sie Haufen von zwei
verschiedene Wege und dann du
fragen ob ich das machen will
weil ich das nicht machen will, weil a
reich ist sechs Jahre extrem wütend
es zeigt ein Design, das oft verrückt ist
Ich glaube, wir suchen Sicherheit
draußen, während wir uns
sind in Gefahr, weil wir es sind
Gefangene der alten Wege
zu denken und das ist gefährlich
dass wir lernen müssen zu berücksichtigen ist
dass alles, was wir gelernt haben, war
vielleicht gut für die Vergangenheit, aber das
Situationen ändern sich ständig
Veränderung
es ändert sich auch eine Situation, die wir haben
gelernt, sich gegen die Situation zu wehren
um die Sicherheit von vorher wiederherzustellen, aber
in den meisten Fällen ist es so
irreversibel
die Situation ist unumkehrbar
verlieren Sie Ihren Job, es ist irreversibel
dann hast du die wahl die du kannst
Rufen Sie Ihren Anwalt an, um zu klagen
Ihr Chef zur Wiedereingliederung in die Gesellschaft
Wer hat dich gefeuert, du gewinnst dich
alle zurück an die Arbeit
hasse dich die Beziehung ist schmerzhaft
mit allen, aber du hast gewonnen
aber Sie sind und ein elendes Leben oder
na dann sagst du dir jetzt
Ich habe meinen Job verloren
Was ist der andere Job i
finden, was ich tun kann
vielleicht kann ich was neues lernen
Sprache
Ich kenne die Berufsausbildung
anders Ich finde einen Job
besser als vorher
Ballast und Höhenänderung
aber wir sehen das, wenn wir kämpfen können
gegen etwas Wertvolles
tun es aber meistens
Es ist wie der Wind, den du nicht kannst
Gehen Sie mit einem Ballon gegen den Wind
Ich kann nicht gegen die Stadt vorgehen, die wir haben
eine Krankheit wir werden alt wir haben ein Problem
finanziell usw.
wir sind nicht unbedingt dafür verantwortlich
was mit uns passiert wofür wir verantwortlich sind
was wollen wir tun, um durchzukommen
raus und mehr raus
hoch nach dem als zuvor schien wiegen
zwischen der gamache straße unserer einstellungen
Northbridge, die ihn wirklich überrascht hat
wenn ich die zeit anhalte, halbzeit
integrieren wenn ja und meine halten
Mutterinsel lebt in ihrem Bad Philippe
so setzen Sie eine Einstellung an die geschwenkt
filet und rosine saint laurent d'arce ex
Thomson kündigt Oberbürgermeistergrenze an
aber wie wir von der Antillen-Guerette
Es war eine verrückte Situation
denn am Tag vor der Abreise gibt es
eine Pressekonferenz
es gab vielleicht 150 Journalisten
dass ich erklärte, dass alle unsere
Kandidaten Milliardär Richard Branson
Steve Fossett hatte gefehlt und dann nur mich
der kleine schweizer ich würde jallet nachfolgen
drei Wochen um die Welt geflogen
am nächsten Tag nach sechs Stunden Flug
Ich war im Mittelmeer, also habe ich
nicht Fallschirmspringen, aber Jahre
Ich musste den Ball ins Meer werfen
Mittelmeer
weil wir ein Kerosinleck hatten
das kam in die Kapsel
begann zu ersticken, es konnte
explodieren, wenn es einen Funken gab
Es ist wahr, dass es eine Situation war
gefährlich
Nun, wir dürfen nicht in Panik geraten, wir müssen
müssen tun, was wir tun müssen, ist
alles nein nein wenn du panisch bist
Du bist verloren, aber das ist der Grund
Es ist interessant, diese Präparate in
Hypnose, weil Sie vorher visualisieren
um alle möglichen Probleme zu verlassen
und wie Sie diese lösen können
ruhiger Weg
Wenn Sie in Panik geraten, sind Sie tot, wenn Sie
Bleib ruhig, du hast eine Chance dazu
Geh raus
Gut, dann habe ich den Ball reingelegt
das Wasser der Ballon sank die Kapsel a
schwebte der Ballon sank
dann gehe ich nach Hause und dann musste ich
eine Pressekonferenz abhalten cinar est
Ausgang dort ist ein Boot, das ein Boot ist
Französische Küstenwache, die kam
Suche nach USA
und wer hat uns dann mit dem schnellboot zurückgebracht und
dann musste man was erklären
war geschehen
Reicht das
der schlimmste Ausfall in meiner Stadt und von
Dort werden Sie geimpft
von dort werden Sie geimpft
du willst das meiste machen
erstaunlich und macht dich zum Größten
Versagen
habe ich das auch verstanden
Moment gibt es, dass alle lachen
alle die lachen
das ist, was sie Angst haben, es zu versuchen
wahre Pioniere wahre Unternehmer
Sie haben mich angerufen, sie haben mir gesagt, wir
wir unterstützen dich
Sie haben es versucht, Sie sind gescheitert, wir ermutigen und
Beim nächsten Mal wird es dir aber gelingen
diejenigen, die keine Pioniere von sind
Unternehmer diejenigen, die Angst haben
Raus aus ihren Gewissheiten die, die es haben
Angst, genau die zu verpassen, die sie sind
alle glücklich, wenn du dich vermisst hast
viele hasser cobourg als bob
Tut mir leid, dass du viele Freunde hast, wenn
Sie verpassen nicht, was die Leute sagen
Es ist wunderbar, wo er an dieser Tatsache gescheitert ist
so lange, dass kendrick auf und
ja, aber weil wir es versucht haben
in meiner Mannschaft
jeder Versuch anders
Richard Branson Steve Foitt hatte er
Milliarden hatte er Ideen und
Name Team, aber jedes Mal, wenn er
verpasst sie wieder aufzubauen ist ihre
Ball auf die gleiche Weise und sie
benutzten ihren Ballon auf die gleiche Weise
Wie Buckler es tat, war a
schlechte Technologie eine schlechte
Strategie und sie reproduzieren und
jedes Mal die gleichen Fehler, also verpasste er
jedes Mal aus dem gleichen Grund
Ich habe aus dem gleichen Grund nicht gefehlt
mir jedes Mal, es ist ein anderer Grund
also jedes mal müssen wir das verbessern
verbesserte Technologie die Strategie von
Flug und dann das dritte Mal gut wir
hatte eine erstaunliche Kugel, die
viel viel weniger verbraucht
Benzin als das der Wettbewerber und wir konnten
Fliegen Sie 20 Tage, was riesig ist
der längste Flug der Geschichte
Luftfahrt
er nennt mich union fritz thyssen est
gestellte Natur
seine Einführung das Ende seines Mandats
Wurden Liste ertrunken, aber Sie sehen
deshalb ist es wichtig
verstehen, was uns lehrt
unser Leben soll Gewissheiten haben
Gewohnheiten haben und weitermachen
immer auf der gleichen Höhe in der gleichen
Richtung
und wenn die Winde des Lebens uns verändern
ist verloren, weil wir das nicht haben
diese Freundschaft mit unbekannt und
das muss geändert werden
Menschen müssen verstehen
dass das Unbekannte die Fragezeichen
Zweifel sind Reize
unglaublich stark für unsere
Kreativität für unsere Vorstellungskraft und
für unsere Leistung
Solange wir in der Routine sind, sind wir es nicht
nicht effizient sind wir uns nicht bewusst
ist auf Autopilot
aber wenn Sie den Piloten schneiden
automatisch am anfang bist du ein wenig
verloren sag dir, was ich gehe
Ich verstehe nichts mehr, ich bin ich
bin aber dann mitten im unbekannten
Sie werden durch das Unbekannte dazu gezwungen
irgendwas damit muss man haben
sich selbst und alles zu hinterfragen
Plötzlich entdeckst du etwas
ist viel wichtiger als die
Mut ist Vertrauen mit dem
Mut du kämpfst gegen die Angst
es kann aber mit dem klappen
Vertrauen
Sie sehen das in der Tat Ihre Situation
Freunde vor eigenen Ressourcen
Ihre Kreativität Ihre Leistung
Ihres Potenzials und plötzlich ja
Ich habe alles drin
mich
und auch wenn die Situation sehr ist
schwierig, du sagst, ich habe das Zeug dazu
in mir und ich werde versuchen, diese zu erreichen
Krisen jagt
tigran stadion bertrand piccard tropisch
info jacques cousteau nicht autorisiert in
August diese Flaschen, wer will, war es
ein Mythos, weil sie Lancy berühren
szajner gut, Physik zu haben, die wir nicht kennen
aber Sohn und Tochter eines Films verpasst
startet diese Bathyscaphe dabei
der Minister oder eine Driving Range aus Strasssteinen
und Cops und Justin Time ist es eins
Hörbericht wird vom Sprecher unterzeichnet y
movida 10 in acht Jahren sind wir jeder
Wir brauchen keine Tricks und kein Rind
Straße
[Musik]
Zuschauer jeder Höhepunkt in Venedig und in
Ich bitte dich, gib mir mich und dich
kennen diesen Familienvater und Großvater
hat mir Lust aufs Entdecken gemacht
Außenwelt
Wissenschaftstechnologie
Erkunden der Welt, aber ich hatte eine
Mutter auch
Ich persönlich engagiere mich hier und
meine Mutter hat mir alles beigebracht
psychologisch-philosophische Seite
spirituell und sie war es, die mir gab
möchte diese Dimension vertiefen
aus unseren Psychiatern so die Welt
draußen ist es mein Vater und mein
Großvater die innere Welt ist mein
Mutter, also ist es wahr, dass ich hatte
Zum Glück hatte ich beides
zwei Pole, die nach oben gehen und Beispiele geben
und das brachte mich dazu, mich selbst verwirklichen zu wollen
auf diese Weise gibt es mani mani
aber das heißt, dass ich das für denke
Menschen, die nicht das Glück haben, zu haben
auf so etwas aufmerksam gemacht worden
vielleicht musst du worte verwenden
anders, aber letztendlich ist es so
genau so, wie du geboren wurdest
in einem Slum in Bangladesch
Nun, es gibt Leute, die es schaffen
an Leuten vorbeikommen, die es schaffen, durchzukommen
Frage gibt es Menschen, die
es schaffen, etwas zu tun
anders als ihr Leben zu bleiben
ihre Slums
Es ist ziemlich mysteriös, ich weiß nicht
warum es bei manchen funktioniert und
andere funktionieren nicht, ich glaube, es gibt sie
sehr viel eine Frage der Datierung sie
die Begegnungen, die wir im Leben haben
sind sehr wichtig
es kann das Treffen mit seinem Lehrer sein
Von der Schule kann es ein Nachbar sein
Es könnte jemand in der Familie sein
vielleicht ein Freund, es könnte zufällig sein
Mais
für diese Art muss man immer offen sein
Begegnungen, die uns wieder hineingeworfen haben
Frage, die uns zeigt, dass es gibt
andere Wege denke ich
Beispiele, die gesehen werden können, sind
wichtiger manchmal gibt es Menschen
die aus ihrem Leben steigen, weil
Sie haben mürrische Rollen
Sie haben Bilder, die sie haben wollen
Das kann ein Fußballspieler folgen
kann ein Filmschauspieler sein
mir waren es Astronauten
Pioniere der Luftfahrt
aber jeder kann versuchen, das zu finden
es stimmt, dass in bestimmten Situationen
wenn wir kämpfen
essen und wir haben nichts zu essen nichts zu
Getränk, um das wir uns keine Sorgen machen können
Philosophie, aber vielleicht ist das, wo
die Verantwortung derjenigen, die die haben
glücklich, diese Art von Leben haben zu müssen
aussprechen
wir müssen anderen helfen, wir müssen helfen
andere ihren Weg finden
und dann anderen zu helfen ist es nicht
nur um Geld zu verteilen I
denke, es ist zu verteilen
Mitgefühl bedeutet, Respekt zu verteilen
es werden auch Trinkgelder verteilt
Wie können wir das tun?
das ist auch der Grund, warum ich gebe
Interviews in afrikanischen Ländern
Ich habe meine Stiftung einen Tropfen Wind von
die Hoffnung, die sich um Kinder kümmert, die haben
vergessene Krankheiten unbekannt in der
die meisten elenden Länder wie gewohnt
ist eine grausame Krankheit namens es ist
eine Krankheit der Kinderarmut, die
nicht genug zu essen haben und wenn die
Mutter hatte währenddessen nicht genug zu essen
Schwangerschaft erhöht die
Problem sind Kinder, die haben
Immunstörungen, die eigentlich
sich nicht ausreichend wehren
Bakterien im Mund, die angreifen
das Gesicht haben Sie Kinder, die
Gesicht verlieren, gibt es riesige Löcher
das Beste aus dem Gesicht und das ist
schreckliches Zeug, also ist es wahr, wenn wir es haben
glücklich, so etwas erlebt zu haben
ließ uns aufblühen
unsere Verantwortung ist es, auch zu helfen
andere zu gedeihen und zu tun
etwas für sie 26. zu vermasseln
Richtlinien
Phildar wird schmelzen wie Schafe
Woods kippt seine Diven, indem er a anwendet
sehr hässliche Hausaufgabe, denke ich
das in jeder Situation, die sich ergibt
Diese Frage müssen Sie sich stellen
dass ich kämpfen muss, um mich zu verändern
Fakt ist, ich muss Pilot sein
Akrobatik und Kampf gegen den Wind
denn da kann ich was ändern
Ding oder nicht, wo will ich
ein Ballonpilot sein, das geht mit
Wind, weil er das nicht ändern kann
Wind und der nur sich selbst ändern kann
mit einer anderen Höhe und sehr oft
wir lernen, das Gegenteil zu tun
Also, wenn es etwas wir gibt
kann sich nicht ändern
wir lernen zu kämpfen und das ist der
Stress und wenn es Dinge gibt, die wir
könnte sich ändern
Nun, wir tauschen nicht und das war's
Fatalismus und übrigens müssen wir das wirklich
verwalten, Dinge zu trennen und
deshalb ist es weise zu unterscheiden
einander ist es sehr sehr
wichtig, denn das ist es, was wir tun
gibt vielleicht die Orientierung unserer
muss seine Energie ins Leben stecken
ob es nützlich ist, aber ob es nicht ist
vollständig verloren
Ich weiß nicht, ob mein Zeichen einzigartig ist
aber bei großen Sequenzen mehrere
Fälle sind umstritten, wenn die Schwelle entgegengesetzt ist
weil ich ein bisschen ketzerisch bin
in der Ketzerei haben etwas anderes gewählt
dass das offizielle Dogma
sondern auch in meinem Medizinstudium
Ich war völlig ketzerisch
Ich habe gelernt, dass ich Kurse von den meisten besuche
steile Ablehnung macht medizinische Klasse
indische ayurveda ich habe kurse gemacht
Traditionelle Chinesische Medizin
denn was mir beigebracht wurde
Uni war mir nicht genug
beantwortete die Fragen nicht
Ich war vor einem Tag in der Stadt
Patient, den ich gesehen habe, als ich drin war
Notfälle als Schülerpraktikant
sie hatte gewollt, dass er sich umbrachte, weil
dass sie den Sinn des Lebens nicht verstand
und am nächsten Tag erhebe ich meine Hand
das publikum 400 studenten hebe ich auf
Gib deinen Psychiatrie-Unterricht ab, je mehr ich
Bitten Sie die Lehrer, auf das zu hören, was ist
was wir mit jemandem machen, der es will
Selbstmord begehen, weil er es nicht versteht
Sinn des Lebens und er antwortet mir hier eins
lehrt dich, Ärzte zu sein, nicht einer
Priester daher für alle Fragen
spirituell
Sie müssen Leute in die Kirche schicken
beim psychiater und das wars
dachte das wäre komplett falsch
aber völlig falsch können wir nicht
die geistige Welt von der Welt abschneiden
Therapie oder die Welt von allem
Tage kommt der Patient, der kommt, mit ihm
sein Leben mit seinen Ängsten mit seinem
hofft mit seinem Leiden und es ist zu
uns an ihn anzupassen als
Therapeut und deshalb war ich es
gesucht überall sonst und wo ich habe
Am schlussendlichsten fand wer mich
Matched 7 und Hypnose mit Hypno
Ich behandelte für 20 Jahre und das
funktioniert so gut, weil wir
lehrt Patienten, diese wiederzuverwenden
Ressourcen
der Patient, der zu uns kommt, ist es
normalerweise zu einem Symptom geschrumpft
stellt sich ganz auf sein Problem ein
mit hypnose holst du ihn da raus
Problem, ihnen eine Existenz zu geben
insgesamt ist das Symptom oder Problem
wird ein kleiner Teil von ihm und
es ist mehr Lanthier und wenn Sie
bekommen, um den Menschen Geschmack zu geben
eine Suchöffnungsdimension
Sie können sie dann auch wieder verbinden
Spirituelle Welt
erst dann Berufswelt bzw
Familie also endlich mein Zustand
Geist als Entdecker und ich glaube
so kann ich antworten
Das Beste zu Ihrer Frage ist, dass ich
bin nie zufrieden mit dem, was ich
Sehen Sie, ich will immer mehr, ich werde
immer besser, gib mir eine Antwort
es reicht nicht, wenn sie es mir zeigen
etwas ist mir nicht genug also ich
mehr erfahren möchte ich setzen möchte
zusammen all die verschiedenen Elemente
es ist wie in der religion
Ich bin ein Christ, aber Religion
Mit Christian ist sie nicht genug
Gottes Erklärung und Erklärung
von Leben und Tod, die wir lernen
in die bibel stelle ich gerne
Taoistische Erklärungen von Erklärungen
buddhistische schamanische erklärungen
großartige Wohngeschichte all das
zusammen wird das für mich eins
Puzzle mit Teilen, die Sinn machen
viel vollständiger, als wenn sie es getan hätten
nur in einer kleinen Vision
dogmatisch ein hexenmeister doc martin und
christophe michalak 18.6 mit einer schere
beim Schreiben von Sedimenten in int und stanhome
toyas schriftlich moblin place d'arme
Krise und ja, es ist wahr, auch wenn es in Ordnung ist
eine Frau zu sein, weil es folgt
diese korallen die krise die fabrik von st jean
ist nicht ganz ganz
diese ganze Corona-Krise
heute ist ein Abenteuer, aber
es ist ein Abenteuer in dem Sinne, dass es
nimmt uns aus unserer gewöhnlichen Welt von
unsere übliche Welt, um uns zu setzen
in einer Situation, die ist
außergewöhnlich und dann haben wir die Wahl
Wir haben die Wahl, uns selbst zu sagen, dass es schrecklich ist
Ich will das nicht und wir leiden und zum des
Prämien und es wird schreckliche Krise oder
so sagen wir uns die Welt, bevor sie war
eine Welt, die instabil, zerbrechlich war
unfair verschmutzen gefährlich
Was können wir jetzt
wie neue Welt machen und das
wird zu einem kreativen Abenteuer
außergewöhnlich, sich selbst zu sagen, es gibt a
eine andere Welt, die möglich ist
Wirtschaftshilfe und Finanzhilfe
die jetzt an Unternehmen vergeben wird
können an Auflagen geknüpft werden
dass der wirtschaftliche Wiederaufbau ist
auch viel nachhaltiger
viel sauberer viel mehr
effizient viel respektvoller
die Umgebung
Heute müssen wir eine Welt bauen
wer ist besser als der, der war
bevor es eine außergewöhnliche Gelegenheit ist
denn vorher ist alles schwierig
ändern, wenn heute alles funktioniert
funktioniert nicht mehr, also musst du bauen
etwas, das besser funktioniert
als vorher und das war's endlich
das ist die Höhenänderung in
Krise
ist es, die Krise zu nutzen, um auszusteigen
verstärkt im Vergleich zu vorher und durch
niedriger oder auf gleicher Höhe herauskommen
mrs und sylvie chalaye indie ihre krise
und was geht wenn phil und andré medjani
Gesicht
Hindi seine Abdeckung ist weich
Sie wissen, es gibt immer Leute, die
Widerstand gegen Veränderung und Mangel
alles ist eine Gelegenheit, die das Leben ihnen gibt
und dann haben sie ein elendes Leben und
Fragen, warum
und dann gibt es die anderen Leute, die
sagen bei jeder Gelegenheit
was könnte ich damit machen
wie kann ich verwenden
das und ihr Leben erschließt Blüten und
verbessert sich in der Gesellschaft, es ist dasselbe
was du heute weißt, hast du
Parteien und Unternehmen
der jeden Tag am Telefon schrieb
überall zu Lobbyarbeit
Rückkehr in die Welt vor zurück zu setzen
fossile Brennstoffe als erste
Energiequelle wieder herzustellen
umweltschädliche Autos auf den Straßen für
sanieren Sie schlecht isolierte Häuser mit
alte Heizungsanlagen damit
Menschen leben
aber das hatten wir vorgebracht
Katastrophe ich mache ich genau
umgekehrt und es ist interessant, weil
als mit dem Fundament auf der Ringmaus
Ich habe 12 Geschäftsinhaber zusammengebracht, die
sind riesige Unternehmen
multinationale Unternehmen und gemeinsam haben wir geschrieben
ein Forum k in verschiedenen veröffentlicht
Medien zu sagen, dass wir eine Welt wollen
anders ist und dass wir wollen, dass die Welt klein ist
Vorschriften berücksichtigen
Umwelt viel viel mehr
ehrgeizig, damit die Krise dient
etwas ist die Welt einschließlich durch
eine gerechtere, nachhaltigere Welt sein
respektiert die Umwelt
die Bestätigung dort ist die dort ist der Regisseur
General von Nestle
Es ist kein kleines Geschäft, das es gibt
Besitzer von lvmh gibt es die gibt es a
bank bnp paribas
es gibt airfrance com fluggesellschaften
sie alle wollen sich damit nachher verpflichten
die Krise trug mehr zu ihrem Geschäft bei
eine Welt viel mehr zu machen
respektvoll gegenüber der Umwelt und
die Lösungen existieren, das ist es
wichtig vor zehn Jahren gab es keine
nicht die Lösungen
heute existieren sie, sie sind
finanziell rentabel, damit wir können
verwenden
[Musik]
Ein Arzt ist in Rom 10 Event 21
Borchardt-Druck erforderlich
Führer Opfer zu holen war es wert
ein Leben wie Stilreligion oder
pjanic meriem verantwortlich im advent zu
Anonymität Stadt der Sünde, in die Sie sich wagen sollten
die Köpfe, von denen wir hoffen, dass ich darin träume
dabei halbe Verbrauchsteuer Reaktionszeit
abdi osman aktienindizes gemacht a
fallen lassen, die nicht passieren, wenn das Ticket und der Name
Thierry Cain diese charmante Präsenz
diskret vor unseren Organen und
Ibrahimovic macht Alarm Wertschätzung
Anne Fort ist ein gleicher Wunsch
verstehe das, wenn Tokyo ein Ultimate ist
zwischenstopps durch konflikt und in edmonton in
honda scritti intime situationen
Pferde Kühe Luxus werden wir dort lernen
die USA nicht wert
Ich in der Umfragezeit im Brendlé-Stil
Wir treffen eine junge Yacine, die viel sagt
die anderen Probleme
für andré mba obame eine einflussreiche gruppe
mit andré unter freunden war es aber
Psychodrama kaufen einige
vivendi zugetta nur feiner schaumabend
Lyrische Kunstfamilie hatte zehn Piloten von
Sony Music of Mind ist in diesem Stirnband eingeschaltet
pilot chip du tanzt da menschlich
Rechte überwachen
Anwendbar hier werde ich es sehen, wir waren
in einer Situation, in der das Flugzeug flog
wo das Wetter endlich perfekt war
zwischen Japan und fliegen
Hawaii
Es gab ein kleines Detail, das machte
dass die Ingenieure in Panik gerieten, aber er
muss man sehen, dass in a
Projekt wie das die Ingenieure auf der
Um ein Flugzeug zu bauen, sind sie nicht da
ein Abenteuer das Abenteuer führen
es waren andré borschberg und ich wer
wird die Führung so vor einer Weile
wo es eine Übertragung der geben muss
Energie
andere, die das Flugzeug bauen und
diejenigen, die es benutzen
und die Ingenieure bekamen es
Mit diesem Flugzeug verbunden, liebte er es
so sehr und ich glaube, er liebte uns
auch andré und ich wollten das besonders
nicht, dass etwas passiert, sondern wenn
Wir waren nach Japan zurückgekehrt
Nie verlassen
es war der Saisonauftakt
taifune die japanische traumfahrt a
behördliche Untersuchung, um dies herauszufinden
warum wir zurückkommen mussten und wir
niemals verlassen hätte und das Projekt
wäre zerstört worden
und ich hatte als Ziel, dass das Projekt
arbeitet andré zugestimmt
Mach weiter, sie war an der Reihe, das zu stehlen
hätte ich sein können, er war es aber der
Entscheidung ist genau die gleiche in
Fall wie diesem müssen Sie tun
Sprung ins Unbekannte
hier produzieren wir nicht
eine Fluggesellschaft mit
Verantwortung für 200 Passagiere in
Fliegen ist ein Abenteuer
Experimental-
Es ist eine Demonstration dessen, was wir können
mit erneuerbaren Energien machen
Nun, ein gewisses Risiko muss man eingehen
also waren wir bereit, es zu nehmen
riskiere so viel audrey wie ich wir hatten
Fallschirm ein Rettungsboot auf
wiederhergestellt werden konnte
Wir hatten seinen Weg schon früher akzeptiert
wirklich geklebt und andré tasche nicht eins
Momente, die ich markiere, werden sortiert
oder ethnie station mont tauch petit then
wie er derjenige im Flugzeug war
er war es, der die hatte
das letzte Wort, das er hätte sagen können, ich
nach Japan zurückgekehrt, aber ich tat es nicht
mit einem Beamten verbunden bin ich
verbunden mit jemandem, der das gleiche hatte
Abenteuerlust und das war klar
er würde weitermachen und es ist klar
dass ich an seiner Stelle hätte
Fortsetzung auch Sie wissen, dass ich das glaube
Wir versuchen immer unsere Welt
vor null risiko und null risiko
es ist sehr gefährlich, weil die Helden
Risiken, die uns nicht lehren, zu finden
Lösungen, wenn Sie es lernen
einem gewissen Risiko ausgesetzt
wir lernen, viel wachsamer zu sein
viel konzentrierter viel mehr
effizient und das hilft uns dabei
vorwärts gehen
das größte Risiko in der Stadt war
Gehen Sie niemals Risiken ein, sagt er
was am schwierigsten war
zwei für einen Sitz in einem sein
Cockpit im Ballon Da war es einfach
Es gab zwei Klassen, das heißt
Ich, der Sky Copilot wählt
Ich habe mich für Brian Jones entschieden, weil ich
dachte es wäre jemand
toll und wir haben uns sehr gut verstanden
Nun, wir haben gelernt, miteinander zu kommunizieren
ein spiel auf malta wir werden darüber reden
solar inc war es notwendig, die zu teilen
Flüge so andre war ein besserer
Pilot als ich, aber ich hatte
die Erfahrung einer Erkundung wie
Entdecker, die er nicht hatte
jemals zehn 20-Tage-Flüge angeboten hatte
in Luftballons etc.
Also mussten wir uns die Flüge teilen
auf eine Weise, die manchmal ein bisschen ist
widersprüchlich
weil wir beide wollten
einige Flüge machen, die wir wollten
die es22 soll den gleichen Zweck haben
dieses Buches war es wirklich zu zeigen
komm rein andré und ich was geht
hinter einem ähnlich großen Abenteuer
über neunzig teilnehmen ist ja ja
vollständig
aber wir waren dabei sehr transparent
ganz ehrliches Buch und wir bekamen
sagte mit andré am ende des abenteuers
möchte zeigen, wie es in der ist
hinter den Kulissen
weil ein Flugzeug auf einem fliegen sehen
segeln um die ganze Welt
schöne Landschaften ok das ist was die
Medien zeigten
aber um dorthin zu gelangen, gibt es, was es gibt
was ist los was ist los
Konflikt gibt es, was Rivalität gibt
Welche Art von Freundschaft usw
es ist so lustig, weil ich einen habe
Patienten, die mir gesagt haben, dass dieses Buch ist
ein Paartherapiebuch mit meiner
Frau zum Anwenden von Notizbüchern während
schuss tatsächlich den ehemaligen präsidenten beschlagnahmt
scripte aber bei 6 min win
Zyklonkrise Richemont Bret Wurzeln
spirituelle Liste extremer Sprachen
sport ja mir finde ich das mittel
Extremsport ist ein Weg
etwas neu verbinden
von Essential bis Care, um aus allem herauszukommen
Es ist Routine all dieser Sicherheit
wer beruhigt uns und wer schließlich
bringt nicht viel an Kapazität
Übertragung
also mich hat das schon immer interessiert
dass die Krisen des Lebens könnten
und meine medizinische Abschlussarbeit mitbringen
es war die Pädagogik der Prüfung und
Ich habe Männer und Frauen interviewt
die schreckliche Tragödien erlebt haben
in ihrer Stadt und ich habe sie gefragt
wurdest du dadurch gestärkt
diese Dramen oder bist du, was du gewesen bist
Gebrochen von diesen Dramen ist die Sache
Das Erstaunlichste, was herauskam, ist
dass fast alle sagten, dass wir es waren
verstärkt kamen wir mehr raus
stark, aber stärker in Bezug auf unsere
Beziehung zu uns selbst und zu anderen
unser Verhältnis zur Spiritualität
Suche nach einer Philosophie die einen Sinn hat
Leben
wohingegen vor dem Leben etwas war
etwas Offensichtliches und wir haben uns nicht gefragt
Frage und und und schließlich bin ich es
denke die Hauptsache im Leben an
darüber hinaus Ballons Flugzeuge
Krisen Abenteuer etc was ist das
was wir mit der Existenz machen wollen, was ist
die Bedeutung, die wir ihm geben wollen
wenn wir denken, wir kommen aus dem Nichts und
dass wir nirgendwo hingehen und dass das Ziel ist
reich und glücklich zu sein
die kleinste Krise wird uns umbringen
wenn wir verstehen, dass wir irgendwo herkommen
verlassen, aber wir wissen nicht, wohin wir gehen
woanders und wir wissen es nicht oder auch nicht
dass der Sinn des Lebens darin besteht, sich weiterzuentwickeln
ist auf mehr als zu verbinden
Weisheit mehr Freundlichkeit mehr Mitgefühl
[Musik]
mehr positive Energie Energie
subtil damals und gut alle
spirituelle Wege überhaupt
Religionen und alle Philosophien
Sinn machen, weil sie sagen
fast alle gleich
Sie sagen fast alles, was Sie brauchen
erhöhen unser Bewusstsein unsere
Mitgefühl unsere Weisheit zwei Qualitäten
Energie zu entwickeln und schließlich
sich in einem System oder in einem wiederfinden
Welt, in der es weniger Dualität gibt
Konflikt Monate des Leidens und der Stimme
buddhist das interessante alles ist still
Gehen Sie buddhistisch, um aus dem herauszukommen
Leiden, das dem Leben innewohnt
mit mehr Abstand ist die Scheibe
verboten und chloé big zu unterschreiben hat
registriert in großer Mischung, die Varrault schimpft
mich jean veil, der erraten hat, was sie
sagte ein totaler Krieg in der
Panarabische Wehrmacht zu diesem Problem
26.000 Fragmente aus dem 18. Jahrhundert
Stunden starben unter der rosa Haubenkunst
gemacht bei Patienten bei Büßern 18 Uhr und
marthe hassen, sagt er, es wird sein
nicht geholfen, mit tm in Kontakt zu treten
Problem ein großes und quesnoy, denke ich
Sie sehen, wir sind in einer Welt, die hat
erschaffen wurde und in der ganzen Schöpfung
Es gibt Dualität, die du nicht kannst
eine Phase haben, ohne die andere zu haben
es gibt tag und nacht
es gibt gut und böse es gibt weiß und
Schwarz
es gibt das linke und das rechte alles und
Duelle gibt es das Leiden und es gibt die
Glück und das ist, weil die Welt
existiert nun in Materie
vor Zehntausenden von Jahren
dass es Propheten gibt, Eingeweihte von
Weisen des Messi, der ankommt und er sagt
für den Menschen, das ist nicht das Ziel
Ziel ist es, aus dieser Inkarnation herauszukommen
in Materie zu steigen
spirituell und zurück zu a
Universum, wo es keine gibt
der Dualität ein Universum der Einzigartigkeit und es ist
warum Gott aller Religionen
und in jedem Fall Monotheisten ist
präsentiert als Kraft der Einzigartigkeit
du bist einer in dieser höheren Kraft dort
es gibt kein gut und schlecht das gute und das
schlecht ist es in der welt in der wir sind
Leben
und so müssen Sie versuchen, durch die herauszukommen
spiritueller Weg statt der Weg
der Teria-Liste, die uns leiden lässt
hier vielen Dank als Anhang vorn
Marignane und Geldpreis stagniert
Philippinen Dynamit unterwürfig keine von beiden
Philosophie zu letzterem gebracht a
halt der Filme aller gemeinsam von uns
Angriffe gibt es, die nach einem mae und gesagt werden
inszeniert wird steve an entrollt
der Geist ist ihre Hymne an die
Skripte, solange ich zitiere, es ist die Seele
überhaupt einfach und 10 Pässe
[Musik]
Nein